[Música]
Bienvenidos a una nueva edición de
enlace andino desde Venezuela en este
programa analizaremos La reciente trama
de corrupción denunciada por la
administración de Nicolás maduro que
incluye un desfalto a la industria
petrolera por parte de funcionarios
públicos desde el gobierno se habla de
una lucha frontal contra la corrupción
mientras que desde la oposición surge la
tesis de una purga interna del chavismo
por cuotas de poder
[Música]
la renunciame al Ministerio del petróleo
por denuncias de corrupción en la
industria petrolera sorprendió el país
el pasado 20 de marzo cinco días después
el fiscal anunció la detención de un
grupo de funcionarios públicos diputados
jueces y empresarios que estaban siendo
investigados desde octubre 2022 por
operaciones financieras ilícitas la
mayoría de ellos cercanos al examen un
mes después Aún se desconoce el monto
Real del multimillonario desfalco la
fiscalía tampoco ha confirmado si el
propio ministro uno de los hombres más
importantes del chavismo estaría siendo
investigado según el fiscal general Tere
William saab hasta la fecha 61 personas
han sido detenidas y hay 20 órdenes de
captura por ejecutar se han practicado
172 allanamientos e incautado
propiedades avionetas vehículos y dinero
en efectivo producto de operaciones
ilícitas en la industria petrolera
se logró detectar
una red de funcionarios que valiéndose
de su cargo y sus niveles de autoridad
procedieron a ejecutar operaciones
petroleras paralelas vean esto Ahí
estamos Ya entrando entonces la
modalidad paralelas
a la de petróleo de Venezuela los
detenidos han sido acusados de
apropiación del patrimonio Público
legitimación de capitales y traiciona la
patria las audiencias de presentación se
han realizado de noche y en salas
improvisadas y una sede del servicio
bolivariano de inteligencia el propio
Nicolás Maduro dijo estar al frente de
las investigaciones cuánto cuesta para
ir los recursos
para que vengan
grupos enquistados de mafioso corruptos
y ladrones a meterle la mano a los
recursos que le pertenecen solo a
nuestro pueblo
por eso el castigo tiene que ser
ejemplar entre los detenidos se
encuentra en el ex vicepresidente de
comercio de pedevesa Coronel Antonio
Pérez Suárez El superintendente Nacional
de criptoactivos Joselin Ramírez el
diputado del pcvel Roa y directivos de
la faja petrolífera del Orinoco también
destaca el empresario colombiano Álvaro
Pulido Vargas acusado en Estados Unidos
por lavado de dinero pero cómo se
explican estos niveles de corrupción en
la industria petrolera a raíz de las
sanciones impuestas por Estados Unidos a
pedevesa la asamblea nacional
Constituyente promulgó a finales de 2020
la denominada ley antibloqueo que admite
mecanismos extraordinarios para la
comercialización del crudo venezolano
bajo un esquema de reserva y
confidencialidad la opacidad en las
transacciones dificultó el control sobre
los ingresos petroleros y facilitó aún
más la corrupción en la industria
mientras que algunos portales de
noticias señalan que el dinero
desaparecido por la comercialización de
crudo a través de criptoactivos alcanza
los tres mil millones de dólares la
agencia reuters reveló que son
millones el monto en cuentas por cobrar
de pedevesa tras operaciones con
petróleo venezolano mediante
intermediarios en los últimos tres años
la cifra oficial se mantiene en reserva
el hecho de que Venezuela para operar en
el mercado petrolero tiene que operar en
los mercados negros porque su petróleo
está sancionado amplifica los riesgos de
corrupción y facilita que los corruptos
hagan negocios sin que se den cuenta los
demás el analista Luis Vicente León
coincide en que la corrupción en
Venezuela es un problema endémico a su
juicio esta reacción del gobierno
contrapropios corresponde a que en esta
oportunidad se traspasaron límites
porque ahora van contra ellos que no
fueron contra otros casos individuales
porque tú no robaste el país tú robaste
a maduro
tú robaste el presupuesto del gobierno
para estabilizar la economía dirigente
opositores consideran que más allá de
una lucha contra la corrupción ha
quedado en evidencia una purga interna
del chavismo por cuotas de poder
califican de sí mismo que el propio
presidente Nicolás Maduro diga estar al
frente de las investigaciones dejando
una vez más en evidencia la falta de
independencia de poderes otros
consideran que el problema se salió de
control son ladrones llamando ladrones a
otros ladrones que ellos mismos
corrompieron no Entonces yo creo que si
bien
pueden haber elementos desde
reagrupación o de reajuste entre
familias Esto está fuera de fuera de
control y fuera de sus manos en términos
de la reacción de la opinión pública
datos de la ong transparencia Venezuela
señalan que bajo la administración de
Hugo Chávez y de Nicolás maduro se han
detectado unos 127 casos de presunta
corrupción dentro de la industria
petrolera en los que se han visto
comprometidos más de 42 mil millones de
dólares del patrimonio público
a juicio de Mercedes de freitas
directora de la ong la debilidad
institucional ha permitido que los casos
queden impunes en Venezuela hay
impunidad para los casos de corrupción Y
hasta ahora salvo los sucesos en las
últimas semanas que nos tienen
sorprendidos a todos lo que hemos visto
es que cuando superan la impunidad es
para castigar a lo que se considera un
traidor lo que se considera un enemigo
del gobierno la asamblea nacional que
preside Jorge Rodríguez discute
actualmente la ley para permitir que
todos los bienes incautados puedan ser
destinados a las áreas de servicios
públicos y Seguridad Ciudadana sin tener
que ir a juicio los operativos
adelantados por la fiscalía y la Policía
Nacional anticorrupción han sacudido el
país en momentos en los que la crisis
económica afecta la mayor parte de la
población y en los que El Ejecutivo ha
declarado no contar con los fondos
necesarios para cumplir con las
reivindicaciones salariales exigidas por
los trabajadores públicos especialmente
jubilados y maestros según el fiscal Se
esperan más detenciones en los próximos
días hasta aquí esta emisión de enlace
andino desde Venezuela Recuerden que
pueden sintonizarnos a través de triple
W punto com
[Música]